Welcome to "English in a Minute," where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
Has this ever happened to you?
What was the name of America's first president?
I can't believe you don't remember that.
Come on!
I know.
I know, I've completely drawn a blank.
"Draw a blank?"
She could not remember that George Washington was America's first president...
...because she "drew a blank."
It's another way of saying, "I can't remember something."
There's another meaning, too.
If you're looking for something but can't find it, then you "draw a blank."
In American English, you can use this phrase with friends or in business situations.
And that's "English in a Minute."